across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare i'm preparing my
family for the total destruction of the
power grid the yellowstone super volcano
a financial collapse and protect
themselves and survival is the goal it's
into the spider hole go fast fast fast
fast
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
i'm gonna use
like this
next we go inside the lives of three
committed preppers make your life
miserable you've devised extensive plans
turn the meal worms into a big meal
gone to great lengths
welcome to the armageddon inn i want
everyone to react as if your lives are
on the line and made huge personal
sacrifices to ensure their very survival
maxi pads which can act as bandages i
certainly don't want to have to be
killing my neighbors go upstairs the
experts will assess their extreme preps
and decide if they have what it takes to
face armageddon everybody grab the gun
they want and to survive slam the boat
closed and you load up the shotgun
this is doomsday preppers
[Music]
john major recently moved his family to
idaho to get away from it all
we moved from utah to
have a little more space
and freedom
a trained marksman and avid outdoorsman
john enjoys the country life
i
don't do a lot of things that other
people spend a lot of their time doing i
don't do a lot of sports i don't golf
and he shares his love of nature with
his kids
look at that
so here you have the chicory all right
check under that bud but the purpose of
this hike is not to admire local foliage
anything
oh there's a cricket you gonna eat it
um sure
tastes like frozen cricket
it's like crunchy and then it is like
cream filled
john is teaching his kids how to survive
doomsday by learning to forage and eat
bugs
[Music]
my doomsday scenario is
a series of dirty bomb attacks
in the u.s
dirty bombs combine conventional
explosives like dynamite with
radioactive material to scatter
radiation around a large area
a single dirty bomb detonated in an
urban center can kill hundreds and
expose thousands more to radiation panic
and chaos are all but certain to follow
and cleanup could take months i feel
that there are several
entities
in the world that would attack sovereign
u.s soil with the dirty bomb
anywhere from low-level terrorists to
rogue states
radioactive materials go unsecured and
unaccounted for all around the world
making dirty bombs relatively easy to
build and a constant threat
john believes a series of coordinated
nationwide attacks could spread
radioactive dust throughout the
environment contaminating the food chain
and causing massive food shortages a
dirty bomb is going to disrupt our food
supply because most of our food is going
to be irradiated by the bomb so food
will be scarce you want to see what meal
worms look like john is determined to
prepare his wife heidi and their five
kids for a time when normal food sources
may not be available you want one with a
bug in it yeah
even if it means eating outside the box
my family gets a kick out of eating the
bugs grab me the cricket i am trying out
a new recipe on my crickets with onion
probably cover them with a little
parmesan cheese
you it's wiggling in my mouth
that's pretty good john stores thousands
of frozen insects in his freezer safe
from the effects of a dirty bomb
which he believes could contaminate both
crops and animals outside
even when i was giving my answer to him
for the prom he was coming out of the
field with his gun and i knew what i was
getting into i guess from the beginning
but not too many families go and eat
bugs together as a family activity
kaylee would you grab me a handful more
of crickets please
is this bugs do there are roughly
1462 edible species of insects
while they may not look appetizing these
crickets boast an average of 13 grams of
protein each
making them a superfood
we're going to turn the mealworms into a
big meal
the ability to survive with nearly
nothing gives you a lot of freedom oh
look at the huge one
that one's mine
i cook my insects because
i do have some standards for taste
insect parmesan a lot of other kids
think it's weird to eat bugs
but i think it's nummy go ahead and
serve up guys i didn't really have a big
problem with it i mean it's just food
what do you guys think it's good dad
i believe other people with whom i rub
shoulders on occasion think i am
obsessed
for john prepping is not just a hobby
but a full-time job
he sells emergency seed banks that can
be used after a dirty bomb attack
after doomsday
these seeds will help people provide for
themselves in the aftermath of the
tragedy
john's seed banks include a variety of
vegetable seeds designed to provide
maximum nutrition
today john and his colleague david are
sorting individual seed packets our
initial
packet comes with an acre full of seed
37 000 seeds
in 23 varieties
each pack will provide a family with
enough radiation free seeds to grow
vegetables for four years
i believe that as you help other
people's needs
a lot of times your own needs are
fulfilled look at this that's perfect
here in the united states it's more
people
prepared than in mexico i never heard
about that in my country so we had that
order of 3 500. wow
that sounds that's a great way to
fulfill it that's a big sale
seeds are a perfect proper resource
because when saved correctly they can
last for hundreds and even thousands of
years
they have mobility
and john doesn't expect business to slow
down post-apocalypse in fact he
considers his seeds the perfect doomsday
currency
i myself have 1.5 million seeds in my
current inventory
in a down society we're going to be
bartering
john expects a coordinated series of
dirty bomb attacks to create chaos and
panic and while he wants to provide
others with the means to help themselves
he will not do it at the expense of his
own stores
after the explosions go off
people would be
in a lot of panic anyone that has food
and
shelter is going to be a target on
doomsday
so to keep his most valuable prep secure
from roving marauders john follows the
prepper rule of multiple and secret
storage locations
right now i have three seed banks buried
around the property in
different cash locations
assuming the attack of a dirty bomb
is successful we need to bury the seeds
so that we can have something to go and
restart with
john buries his seed banks for two
reasons compact earth is one of the most
effective shields against radiation
every six inches of earth reduces
radiation exposure by a factor of two
burying the seed banks underground also
controls their temperature allowing them
to last longer
that's going to keep the seeds cold
they'll last up to a good 10 15 years
in this climate
and for john security goes beyond good
hiding places so he wants each member of
his family to be able to defend their
preps and themselves using a variety of
weapons when law of the jungle kind of
reigns at that point every individual is
responsible for his own security i have
at least
1500
rounds of ammo and i have 30 weapons at
my disposal okay
everybody grab the gun they want good
choice brianna
i take my kids practice shooting as
early as i can get them interested
brianna here you go
the majors prefer 22 or 410 caliber guns
because they take only two different
types of light and widely available ammo
a prepper advantage not only because
they are easy to carry but also easy to
replenish in a crisis
by seven years old all my kids have shot
guns
so why are we preparing to shoot to
protect yourself protect yourself good
security shooting is a very important
thing when you're trying to survive all
right things will be getting a lot
tougher in the future for us we need to
protect each other protect ourselves
and
keep bad people from doing bad things
right go ahead and load
the range is hot fire when ready
i would protect my family with all means
possible
and i don't feel i need permission from
anyone to do that
there's really nothing off the table in
my book
for john defense is not just about
shooting he has created a military
security plan for his home
to protect from rioting marauders we
head to the foxhole
a foxhole is known in the military as a
defensive fighting position it allows
soldiers to keep watch over an area
while remaining undercover
take your weapon
it would be a way to provide
surprise surveillance they're going to
approach the home thinking that they're
only having to worry about people inside
the home
but before he can protect his family
john wants to make sure they can survive
the radioactive aftermath of a dirty
bomb blast i want everyone to react as
if your lives are on the line so today
he's about to put his family to the test
of their lives
[Music]
father of five john major is preparing
his family to survive a series of
nationwide dirty bomb attacks that he
believes will threaten infrastructure
and contaminate food sources the series
of dirty bombs would cause the society
to have a meltdown just because of the
sheer panic people would feel
my dad is a
be prepared guy he's different from
other dads
we're gonna come over here and you guys
just immediately run up the stairs okay
the government suggests sheltering in
place in order to avoid contact with
radiation brianna where are you going
you have to grab from here so the majors
have formulated a detailed bug-in plan
which they practice at least twice a
year to take care of our own security we
run drills on
a very regular basis make sure that
everyone's ready and knows ahead of time
how we're going to react what are we
doing the drill for
we have had a
dirty bomb go off here close to us so we
need to get out of the regular
environment everything needs to
be executed as if it's real i want
everyone to react as if your lives are
on the line okay the majors have adapted
one of the rooms in their house into a
shelter zone so as soon as they hear of
a nearby attack they can retreat into
safety all right guys get started we
have a
fall out stay here orderly control
we grab all the supplies we need
go upstairs our bug out bags
and filtration for water and we
run up to the room and seal it off
the whole time i'm just thinking
if this was a real emergency we'd have
to be as fast as we could ever get
they can control their environment by
taping up windows and doors
be careful with your knife
reducing the chance of radiation seeping
in
we also have a pump system that can make
sure that any of the air being sucked in
from the environment is cleaned before
it enters the room
a ventilation system like john's
increases the positive air pressure in
the room keeping any air from outside
out and making sure the only air coming
in is through a safe filter
when i pump the air it felt like i was
helping my family some people
don't think
that you need to have all these drills
and bug out bags they'll think they're
weird you need to make practice practice
makes perfect
john expects that they may have to stay
in their shelter zone for weeks maybe
months so while there he'll use
sprouting seeds to keep his family alive
i would start sprouting immediately
sprouted seeds seeds that have only just
begun to grow are packed with vitamins
and protein a single serving of broccoli
sprouts can offer up to 100 times more
nutritional benefits than mature
broccoli soak them for 24 hours the
sprouting seeds in their bug out bags
will feed the family for two weeks
but ultimately john believes he may have
to dig into their cashed seed banks
before it is safe to go outside so he
has a specially designed suit ready
if we have a dirty bomb holocaust here
the filtration suit
is going to protect you
by stopping particulates in the air that
would get down into your lungs so as we
leave our sanctuary in the room we'll
dig up the seeds we need and just get
out of dodge as fast as we can
and if things do go south in a big way
john has found the perfect vehicle to
get his family out of danger
a retired ambulance we have a van the
bug out mobile it's an old ambulance so
that if we need to
leave in a hurry
it's already
most the way packed our plan would be to
flee either north or south due to most
the winds going east and west
and we just bring out our bug out bags
and off we go
given the
historical and current threat levels i
do not believe i am obsessed with
prepping i feel a lot freer
when i've reached a certain independence
and
providing for the needs and comforts of
the family
john the experts at practical preppers
have identified several pros and a few
cons to your preps
your food and water preps are excellent
and you have gone the extra mile by
preparing your family to live off the
land by foraging
also your firearms will serve not only
for protection but also for hunting
however while your remote location
reduces the immediate threat of attack
we suggest investing in a ham or
shortwave radio to ensure you are able
to maintain communication with the
outside world
i agree with that fully i think cam
radio
is uh
extremely useful and i do intend on
getting my license to operate
the ham and
have one in possession
all right hitting that geo just a quick
update on a couple things we've improved
since the show
we've
got in uh a particle mask that will
adjust to nearly any face
which is better than a traditional gas
mask i have one
for an adult
and also for child
and
we got an ak-47 with some ammo
and we got
60 grain 22 ammo for the long rifle
since 9 11 anti-terror governmental
agencies have been on the lookout for
potential dirty bomb attacks because
producing such a device is relatively
simple and inexpensive and their
psychological impact could be great
however a dirty bomb's blast would
likely cause more damage than the
radiation it spreads
janet spencer has been prepping for a
nuclear attack in her home state of
montana for seven years but how prepared
is she
[Music]
janet spencer is an author living in
helena montana
two hours north of yellowstone national
park
and two hours south from 150 nuclear
weapons operated at malstrom air force
base in the city of great falls
janet believes this missile arsenal is
one of the largest in the world and the
perfect target for an enemy nuclear bomb
if someone wanted to take out our
capabilities of retaliatory nuclear
strikes they would just take out great
falls
preparing for disaster is the only safe
and sane thing to do
when a nuclear bomb falls
everybody within a one mile radius of
ground zero will die
there will be heavy casualties within a
three mile radius due to radiation burns
there is no more power
what water there is
may be radioactive
if you look at a nuclear blast as it's
happening you go blind it's tragic now
that we no longer teach duck and cover
only two nuclear bombs have been used on
people nagasaki and hiroshima
they sure didn't get any warning did
they
those who did survive the bomb released
over hiroshima japan in 1945 were left
homeless and fled
janet believes the same displacement
will occur in montana so she keeps
others at the forefront of her prepping
plan
i began preparing to be able to help as
many people for as long as possible
ninety percent of the people in great
falls would die
that would still leave six thousand
people that survive heading over the
hill to my town
what i intend to do here is taking care
of evacuees
janet thinks the survivors will come to
her city because radioactive fallout
from a bomb detonated in great falls
would travel downwind away from helena
the only place for them to go would be
helena we are the closest population
center that is upwind janet preps her
home nicknamed the armageddon inn alone
but she does not live alone she and her
husband jerry have been married for 30
years but even after three decades
together not all of their interests are
in sync when my husband looks at my
constant efforts at this he is a little
bit bewildered
i don't think the nuclear threat is
nearly as real as it used to be
in fact i would rather believe
there's going to be some great
breakthroughs in energy technology i'm
going to take the dog for a walk
i do a lot of my prepping behind his
back
i will know if he's going out
i have two hours to get my preps done
before he gets back come on elsie
today as she routinely does janet is
taking advantage of jerry's absence to
work on the largest food storage area in
their home beneath their california
king-sized bed
there's nothing to give you peace of
mind like sleeping on top of a metric
ton of food
janet knows nuclear fallout would
deposit in soil and create a massive
disruption in food supplies so she has
collected several thousand canned goods
and over 200 pounds of rice and pasta
i probably have spaghetti enough to feed
a thousand people beans enough to feed 2
000 people
her spaghetti and macaroni collection
alone would be enough to feed over 15
percent of the victims who might make
the trek to helena
my hobby is collecting spaghetti and
that's considered borderline insane
i consider it the safest and sanest
thing i can possibly do
janet has spent the last four years
stacking cans in 42 square feet by
maximizing every single square inch
but the space has finally reached its
full capacity this is the day when i'm
going to call this bed full
and i'm going to close it up seal it for
the final time
[Music]
janet still has time to prep while jerry
is away but to keep her vast and
constantly growing supply out of his
sight she will need to find a new
storage option you wouldn't normally
think of a bathroom door as being a
storage spot but
i think i could probably fit a whole
bunch of suit packets into this door
there's a lot of tricks and tips that i
use
just to to get around the fact that he
doesn't support it and to prevent that
friction from happening that's enough
onion i'm going to switch to chicken
noodles
that might do it
[Music]
anyone cleaning out my house after i'm
dead is going to think i was really
strange
i ended up getting 70 suit packets in
there
the most hazardous nuclear fallout
descends within 24 hours but the finest
grains can travel long distances
carrying radiation with them
janet believes this dust could float
into her home so she has added a layer
of wood for additional protection
i think it's gonna hold
you want as many layers between you and
the outside world of radiation as
possible
janet's innovative hiding techniques
don't just save her marriage they double
as her security plan against desperate
people she believes may ransack her home
in search of supplies
[Music]
i hide my food because if i have vandals
come in after a disaster i want to be
able to just walk away from the
situation and come back later and find
all the food that they've missed because
they didn't think of looking there
in case janet does not survive the
nuclear blast she keeps a written
account of the armageddon inn that will
serve as a guidebook to locate her preps
and what would be her first aid station
if i don't survive
i do want the people who survive me to
be able to utilize what i've stored
here this is my drop ceiling i like to
pack good stuff into it whenever jerry's
away for a little while this is one of
my most super secret hiding spaces that
only i know about
janet is packing her drop ceiling with
first aid kits because she believes many
survivors at the inn will require
medical attention from the bomb blast
which would shatter windows sending
glass shards through the air at 100
miles per hour when the shock wave hits
you your windows are going to shatter
into a thousand pieces
to dress lacerations from flying debris
janet stocks up on an absorbent medical
item made from cellucotten which is five
times more effective than ordinary
cotton
lots of maxi pads which can act as
bandages
maxi pads are very absorbent they're
sterile they're very cheap so i stock up
on a lot of those
because jerry could arrive home at any
minute janet cannot complete putting
away more supplies in her drop ceiling
today
[Music]
when he comes home he says hi honey how
was your day i say oh it was good i just
read a book and fiddled around on the
computer and i would just kind of fail
to mention
that i happened to line the back closet
with canned goods while he was gone
i've seen over the years how much she's
been collecting putting things in
strange places i mean if the end of the
world as we know it does ever occur
it'll all come in handy i'm not
thrilled but
it's there it's part of us
but how will janet escape radiation
sickness if the bomb blast happens
[Music]
janet spencer has spent seven years
preparing for a nuclear attack that
would devastate great falls montana and
send thousands of evacuees to her
hometown of helena
she has enough food to feed over 1 000
people and a security plan in place but
her husband of 30 years does not share
her prepping interest
my husband is part of the population
that feels that it's not his job to be
ready for a disaster
but i can pinpoint the instant that i
became concerned about disasters
4 59 a.m on february 2nd in 1989.
i woke up by an awful explosion that
blew my door open
there's a train collision on benton
avenue how long ago did you hear it just
now
just now a big explosion
train exploded catastrophically in the
middle of helena montana completely
shattering my city
there was a cataclysmic fire there was
no power there was no heat the phone was
not working and i had no idea what was
going on or what i should do then i
thought i would tune into the radio for
the emergency broadcast system to come
on
but all of the radio stations were off
the air
the authorities were absurdly unprepared
from that point forward i don't think i
would ever again in my life trust
someone else to handle the situation
i can either be prepared for a disaster
or not that's the only thing i can
control
because of her past experience preparing
for a communications breakdown during a
nuclear catastrophe is one of janet's
main priorities
whenever there's a nuclear bomb blast it
will blow out the fuses and the wiring
of any electrical appliance
a secondary effect of a nuclear
explosion is called an electromagnetic
pulse or emp
a sudden burst of high voltage energy
that damages electronic devices and
would bring communication to a
standstill
if you want to have communication if you
want to have radios that still work
after a nuclear blast you need to get
them protected by a faraday cage a
faraday cage is a sealed metal container
which creates a barrier against an emp
surge by forcing the electrical current
around instead of through the structure
faraday cages are ridiculously simple to
build i can build a faraday cage in 20
minutes
many preppers spend hundreds of dollars
building faraday cages but janet
searches for materials with a limited
budget in mind
perfect faraday cage
definitely worth a dollar
being able to have an electronic devices
after an emp
priceless in a 2010 national poll over
50 percent of respondents said they fear
a nuclear attack in the next 40 years
but janet worries she's the only one
preparing in helena so she tries to get
others on board
today she is giving her friend kathleen
a faraday cage tutorial so what is this
faraday cage anyway well a faraday cage
will protect your electronics in event
of an electromagnetic pulse so after the
electromagnetic pulse you'll be able to
use whatever's in here you should if we
do it right okay so we have a metal box
now we need to line it so that all of
the things inside of it
have no chance whatsoever of touching
the metal
because metal conducts electricity the
interior of the box must be insulated
with the material that would break the
transfer of electromagnetic waves
you can do that with something as simple
as a pad of newspapers my favorite thing
to do is to use styrofoam let's see
here's these two
walkie-talkies right
janet has 50 walkie-talkie radios and
scanners in case the helena police
department lose communication
capabilities after an emp
i always figured if worse came to worse
i would just go down and provide the
police force with a new set of radios i
have am fm radios up the wazoo
janet is sealing the seams of the box
with aluminum tape which is conductive
and will aid in turning the metal tote
into a veritable shield
and the final step is placing the
faraday cage in an area where it will
also be protected from radiation let's
just hop up back here and
you know i don't know if this job
called for i don't know if it included
crawling back into the i got rid of all
the mice before you got here thank you
very much i really appreciate that
oh my god do you have food stored back
here too you bet i do staying below
ground after a nuclear assault could
reduce radiation exposure by 90 percent
making janet's crawl space the safest
shelter from nuclear fallout in her home
for food and people behind your
insulation oh my gosh look at that
[Music]
janet knows there are thousands of
nuclear weapons in the world some of
which are kept on hair trigger alert if
the doomsday clock strikes midnight she
wants all of her friends to know
the door will be open at the armageddon
inn
and the whole point behind the
armageddon inn is to take in and help as
many people as possible we have decided
a long time ago that if the big one is
we're coming to your house i know we
have our own resources too but we're
coming to you and that's exactly the the
thought that keeps me prepping because i
don't know how many people are going to
show up
there are communities that would pull
together instead of falling apart
i hope that helena is one of those
communities
[Music]
janet you have food and other supplies
to last you for a long time
however you are missing the basic prep
should radiation spread to your area we
highly recommend getting a radiation
meter i think that is an excellent idea
that it's something i will definitely
take care of also it is imperative you
move some of your food supplies to a
separate location because your kindness
may be taken advantage of the backup
plan where that is concerned is a
climate-controlled storage unit which
can be rented for forty dollars a month
before the show airs i will definitely
have one
it's been three months since the film
crews left they gave me some good advice
and i have been busy following up on
much of it i found the cheapest smallest
climate-controlled storage unit i could
find
it's surrounded by a yard that has a
10-foot tall chain-link fence topped
with razor wire so now i have the option
of
walking away from my house if i cannot
defend it
a global arsenal of nearly 20 000
weapons makes the possibility of a
nuclear incident a real tangible threat
however the united states and russia are
moving towards a policy of nuclear
disarmament aimed at reducing the
likelihood of global nuclear war
at the age of 65 colorado retiree jack
jobe could be spending his golden years
relaxing instead he's gearing up to save
his neighborhood from a catastrophic
solar flare
jack jobe is a former marine and a
retired photojournalist who lives
outside denver colorado
neighbors know jack as a funny man who
loves making his wife jackie laugh i
want to have you for dinner uh in fact
we're serving
soylent green
and even trying his hand at stand up at
the local comedy club
i'm not afraid of dying in 2012.
i just don't want to be there when it
happens
but recently jack has gotten very
serious about one thing
prepping
i'm preparing for a massive solar flare
that could set society back hundreds of
years
i'm a brand new prepper
it all looks like learning to me still i
spend 24 hours a day prepping in the
broad sense of things
the pivotal moment when i started
prepping was after i saw the 2010 haiti
earthquake it can only be described as a
nightmare hundreds of thousands of dead
i had a huge revelation that my wife
jackie and i were totally unprepared
in january of 2010 jack was one of
millions across the world who watched as
a 16 year old girl was pulled from a
pile of rubble 15 days after an
earthquake killed a quarter of a million
people in haiti
they'd given up rescue nobody should
have survived that long
the rescue inspired many to believe in
miracles it made jack believe in
prepping
and in a moment and i mean
like that
i had this blinding flash
human beings lives change
in an instant just fail
when i first realized that i needed to
learn more about survival scenarios i
looked at everything from financial
collapse terrorist attack
not large natural events
well that
brought me to solar flares
two years ago at the age of 63 jack's
life changed when he learned about solar
flares sudden bursts of energy released
by the sun
a large solar flare can set off an
electrical pulse with the energy of
billions of hiroshima sized atomic bombs
if a strong pulse reaches the earth it
could wipe out all electronics in its
path effectively sending millions back
to the 1800s
experts predict there's a 12 chance this
will happen in the next decade
if a solar flare massive enough to do
this kind of damage hit right now
all of these vehicles would suddenly
just cease to operate
now people are all going to grab their
cell phone thinking their car is dying
there's no cell phone service within
moments they're suddenly going to
realize this is something catastrophic
beyond our wildest imagination
in jack's apocalyptic vision a solar
flare fries the computer systems of all
vehicles leaving him stranded on the
road miles from home thank goodness i've
got enough preparation and i've got a
72-hour bag but most of these people
don't
i'd wave people away and if they look
like they're going to give me trouble
i'm armed
now i'm faced with a 10
mile walk to get home
this would suddenly turn into a very
very dangerous world
realizing that getting home by foot may
be his only option after a solar flare
jack knew he had to get himself in
better physical condition
everybody was very skeptical about my
prepping when i first got started
because i basically had been a fat old
lazy couch potato he has lost 90 pounds
in the two years since he started
preparing mostly because three days a
week he straps on his 72-hour bag and
walks the neighborhood
does me no good if the event happens and
i can't lift the darn thing so i began
to carry it i realized that was a chance
to talk to my neighbors about being
prepared my name is jack i live in a
house across the street good to see you
what i do is on my business card on the
back i show you just a few little things
that i recommend people carry these days
it could save your life in an emergency
i'm encouraging people like yourself to
learn first aid it's an emergency you're
my doctor and i'm yours you had 10
minutes to get out of your house what do
you have to carry with you what are you
going to do if the neighbors come to you
and they're out of food and you've got
it
the more of my neighbors i can teach
about solar flares the more they're not
going to be hunting jackie and i down to
kill us for our supplies and i certainly
don't want to have to be killing my
neighbors i'd rather talk to them about
it my canned goods in this one all right
all right just because jack likes
chatting with neighbors about prepping
doesn't mean he's telling them
everything like where he keeps his four
months of food supplies
how about that rice box that's good this
one here only jack's wife jackie knows
all the places he stashed food around
their house you just tape it up sink
parts we
look at how to put food in situations
where
we know where it's at but other people
that would come and visit would never
notice it just lay it on its
side slide it all the way to the back
okay
no i'm not a doomsday prepper i'm
married to a doomsday prepper tell me
about your comedy routine being married
to a doomsday prepper means that you
understand you have to have patience
jackie knows that the haiti earthquake
had a big impact on jack
but she believes that's not the only
reason he started prepping
we both have been laid off i think jack
saw things were changing
more quickly than they had in the past
and i think that gave him
thought that we might be in a doomsday
cycle right now
i'm having to now at 64 reteach myself
all of those survival skills that i knew
back when i was a teenager and young
adult even as a beginning prepper jack
considers it foolish to stock up without
a plan to defend his supplies and his
family if a solar flare hit society will
just deteriorate into a ravaging pack of
animals your life can go from great to
just miserable in a moment
how are you set up to cope
if a catastrophic solar flare sends
society into darkness and chaos jack
fears that he and jackie won't be able
to hold off marauders forever
people that don't have preparations are
going to go after people that are
prepared so he's putting the finishing
touches on his post-apocalyptic bug-in
strategy
at an age when most americans are
getting ready for retirement jack jobe
is getting ready for a second career as
a prepper
in anticipation of social chaos after
massive solar flare he's teaching his
wife jackie to fight with knives about
this area of the kitchen and i realized
with this large door here we hadn't made
any plans as a first line of defense
against home invaders jack tapes knives
next to every entrance of the house he
also keeps extra knives under the
counters and in the bedrooms jackie it's
taken quite a while for her to come
around to the idea but when she did
that's when we decided we would practice
for example knife training
if a solar flare brings looters to their
door jackie knows to grab the nearest
one
i now
come in like i'm the intruder
putting more pressure on her in that
stress that adrenaline rush that oh my
god what am i gonna do
i want her to get used to that
[Music]
i'm gonna give you a good run
ladies all right come here and make your
life miserable the more you practice
something the more it becomes natural to
you
if their home comes under siege the jobs
believe their eight hidden knives will
be more useful than one gun
knives are light easily concealed
and silently deadly
that's right that's right all right
that's great hon come on that's great
yep i think you're ready we've been
through the entire
batch of knives all right so we're ready
and if that's not enough to stop an
invader he has a backup plan we're
putting in a safe room and the next
thing we're going to do there we've got
to get a door on it
safe rooms are fortified spaces that
often hold food water and first aid
items they are recommended for hurricane
and tornado prone areas
but jack has different concerns you know
we had a huge gigantic the biggest
recorded one in history uh solar flare
in 2003
and the thing that scares me is we're
not even to the peak until 2012 or 2013.
it's a matter of luck if the earth's in
the way jack's safe room contains 100
gallons of water two months of food and
a 12-gauge shotgun today his friend
mitch is helping him add the finishing
touch a door that locks from the inside
and i just wanted something to help buy
us time and keep jackie safe this should
do it you want to test the latch jack
plans to retreat into the safe room with
jackie as a last resort if they can't
hold off multiple invaders okay works
good okay
my dear your new safe room wow
this looks great show her how the boat
is wow this works come on to me i
understand why
we have a safe room
but the thought of having to lock myself
in there is scary
i love this okay then just get it out
okay you're ready to go
oh this is great
i know i thought you'd be excited yeah
now if you have an intruder the first
thing you do is you run in here slam the
bolt closed and you load up the shotgun
okay
realistically jack expects the door will
only buy him a few minutes just enough
time to load a weapon
the moment we slam that bolt shut on
that
safe room
we've kind of made a declaration the
world is gone
we're either gonna have to start killing
people that are trying to kill us
we're just gonna have to kill ourselves
but i'd rather be prepared for it to
happen
so i'm putting it in
i'm using myself as an example to say
hey if i'm 65
you can certainly do some steps the more
prepared more people are the more people
that will
survive and will be able to cooperate to
build this neighborhood back the way it
was
jack the experts practical preppers
commend you for your outreach to your
neighbors
additionally it is good that you are
getting in shape as this will greatly
increase your chances of survival
i will definitely continue the physical
training it's been a blessing already
with losing the weight
however your safe room is not enough to
protect you and jackie you need to
establish a defensive perimeter around
your home if you want true security from
invaders
i do
want to lay in a lot of traps around the
yard camouflage holes and have
spikes and things set up throughout the
yard
since our net geo television appearance
and the first couple of episodes are out
my wife jackie is actually more
interested in prepping
now what i've done is taken the experts
advice about beefing up our home
security here's the first of three
pieces that will fit inside of each of
our windows
in the event
of looters
the chances of a devastating solar flare
destroying the power grid for millions
of people is as high as 12 over the next
10 years however the majority of solar
flares pose no threat to life on earth
[Music]
you